Oh mash yeah this tells no joke
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today I'm joined by Patriots tight end
Rob Gronkowski or so man how you doing
good man how about you excellent he's
been to four Pro Bowls he has a Super
Bowl ring and you can catch him on his
new show crash Lee it's a Nickelodeon
you know man you're a little pressed for
time so usually we do 10 wings today
we're doing fire that's cool that's the
good news
yes the bad news is we did bring two of
our hottest sauces with us in LA you're
a Buffalo guy but this will push you to
the young Megadeath a sound scary man
are you ready to get a girl now I'm
ready to start with the you know the
first couple like sriracha you know I'm
ready for that one let's let's start
all right sriracha this is no big deal
it's a light one let's try that's a bad
nice nothing so not bad at all
crash leads it's one of these live shows
where you take these epic athlete fails
and you analyze them you crack jokes and
the way that you were brought up with
all those brothers bouncing off the
walls all the time I have to think that
you have some sort of emergency room
story or some sort of Evel Knievel
moment that if camera phones were around
in the 90s would have been a YouTube hit
oh yeah so we kind of do have one we're
all playing mini sticks with actually
all my brothers but my little brother I
went in the middle of them check timing
boom it's actually been aired a couple
times on TV boom he went flying right to
the ground my mom was only holding the
camera all yours my mom scream ha ha and
my brother goes boom right to the ground
actually no the camera shuts off my
brother had to go right to the hospital
get stitches all in here he was like 3
years old at the time so it was pretty
epic you popped him with a check top
them with a check it's mini sticks
anything goes so this is our hot sauce
you're on the hot ones show this is the
hot ones hot sauce we're very proud of
this one
there we go drink up we're tasting the
speaking of growing up I can handle that
one I know that you guys were huge
wrestling fans okay so I've got some of
the legends from the 80s 90s era right
in your wheelhouse I'm gonna show you
them you just tell me the first thing I
sure what you think of them okay I love
this all right back in the days
Glenn Johnson the rock the rock love
them high brow do you smell you do that
bro for me I'll do talk do you smell
what my out sauce is cooking how about
Stone Cold Stone Cold Stunner baby Stone
Cold Steve Austin oh that's my favorite
I love the Stone Cold Stunner stone cold
is your favorite yes I have one of my
favorites the
I say oh my god I think I have something
special to you but first we got to go
Ric Flair Oh
Ric Flair we're just too sweet you don't
know that he was I I know but he did
that one too I'm getting a little
confused heiresses back in my arrow whoo
all right so this last one I had a
feeling this guy would be your favorite
I don't know if he is but I have a
feeling he has a special place in your
heart all right you ready sing
is it Val Venis Oh Val Venis hello
ladies
he whips off the towel which I used to
always do that as a kid growing up
before the shower you put it around you
I looked at myself in the mirror hello
ladies and with the towel around like
him rattles definitely my favorite
wrestling bell Venus is your favorite it
was are you a little bitty what was that
I - I'm impressed I am very impressed
what kind of mentalists yeah but you
knew velvet right I did I was I did I
did see some croc pain 100% these are
kind of free throws now we're great
we're going up a little bit and we're
really amping high let's try it out all
right let's try this pan out
I actually hate this one those bad taste
sure are like miles Nene oh I know
grounds hot sauce that's for taste this
one isn't saying it's just definitely
starting some pain how can I have water
now you can do already after the third
no I got at least water after I can't do
it yet I respect it Oh Ted first we
feast we're very interested in what
athletes eat if you're gonna have some
sort of Last Supper who do you invite
what do you serve well I invited I'll
just invite my closest family my closest
friends and I got to serve one of my
mom's meals we're gonna serve a couple
of ounces it's our last meal so you're
gonna try and stuff down like four
different meals obviously it's your last
one my mom's chicken souffle no we gotta
have her cooking a steak too and some
barbecue chicken and her twice baked
potatoes cause you know she takes out
the potato put cheese sour cream all
that she also does that with hash browns
to twice-baked hash browns off the chain
I'm telling you and then she makes a
good salad just a little start but you
know it's last supper you're really not
trying to eat a salad so take out the
cell we're gonna bring in her desserts
she makes it one of the best cookies off
she makes the best cookie cookies
chocolate chip cookies and the best
birthday cake with some strawberry
filling it and also start off with an
appetizer the mom's buffalo chicken wing
dip and also made here jelly too and you
put that on some Ritz crackers with
peanut butter you're golden backyard
barbecue style on a boat what's the vibe
we're gonna have just grill grill some
girl check in dogs hot dogs burgers
girls and vegetables on the top have
some grilled veggies become eating
healthy at the barbecue you know so
that's it
who's on the sound and Waka Flocka and
Cucaracha okay yeah you know it top 20
Justin Timberlake all that all the whole
top 20 all the hits
all right so this is mad dog 357 not to
be messed with it is no joke really
your teammate there oh listen good
it's horrible it's hot but also like the
tea flavor and what flavoring is out ha
yeah it's like I agree it's like mellow
going to the bar yeah so your teammate
and fellow dead-end Martellus Bennett he
recently wrote a children's book hey AJ
flies in the face of what a lot of
people think of first book I can read
shows but that's not true because you
have a book of my own career was to
advance and you've inspired some crazy
fan fiction but now that you're hosting
the kids show have you ever thought
about also writing the children power oh
man but this tells no joke
Wow ever thought about the children's
book no I leave that up to my teammate
Bert Ellis
he's the genius like that so I'm gonna
leave the writing of children's books up
to Martellus I already wrote a book that
book tour I'm done with books never
doing a book again well let me stop you
right there because I thought of a good
children's book for you in the or on the
way here can I pitch it to ya oh maybe
we talk business after that hurry up
alright so were you always the biggest
kid in the class or did you hit us Oh
always the biggest that is so perfect
the book is called
robbing big news Robby big boots and
it's about a fifth grader who's so big
that he can't wear normal like cool kid
fifth grader shoes you can only wear big
boots and all the kids teased him
they call him Robby big boobs okay he's
the coolest kid though you're sticking
with me right here with me
now I don't know about the middle I
haven't worked out the beat so let's
fast-forward to the end just the
district championship football game our
and Robby big Boots's team is playing in
it but they don't have their field goal
kicker he went camping with his parents
the weekend before and got poison ivy so
he's not with them they have a chance to
win the game winning field goal they
look down the bench and this coach knows
their only shot
Robby big boots bring him out on the
field clears the uh he goes right
through the uprights from 40 yards out
he goes from the kid who is bullied to
not the most popular kid on school
because there's a hero in the building
all right I like it I like it but
I mean you're gonna really write like
how many pages it's a quick story so I
got a workout I did yeah but I liked it
I liked the title Robby big girl love it
so this is the last wing it is Blair's
Megadeth sauce can't even Dage so I
could try to dab the last wing I'm gonna
do it you don't have to I'm not doing
that I don't like to peer pressure
people on this one it is no joke
do I only know if I can do this last one
not mad dog got me Blair's nice vanity
can you man up can you do it I'm like
freshly right now
crash it be I'm crash late eating these
wings so Rob sometimes I feel that
people try to put you in the box they
either try to make you the bro god or
they try to make you the party animal
but I wonder in what ways are you
mischaracterized which ways are you
misunderstood oh man people probably
think I like hot sauce I don't like hot
sauce at all
I like mild medium definitely
mischaracterize there oh well we should
have made that clear in the email out
Rob you made it all the way through hole
5 wings to the house
I'm like dizzy we make you work I'm
shaking but we work for you
30-second plug the floor is yours this
camera or that camera let the people
know what you got going on here oh we
got we got the show crash Lee's going on
oh it's epic fails it's like someone
playing a sports and failing like me
trying to eat this hot sauce of failing
that's how I pick these sports are cos
this hot sauce is making me dizzy
it's making me start sweating and I'm
about to have tears start coming to help
my eyes Rob before you go Kenya can we
grant spike a wing yes Perry let's bike
to get the hot one here this is that
that is to happen dude I'm dizzy right
now so maybe you show me how it's done
in the guys wait mine you take to swing
you just score a touchdown pass you
pissed off at it cuz it just made you
dizzy top and you didn't like it at all
whoa whoa whoa all right
great man alright ready oh oh I give
that a nine
it was it was good for him good
everything but just didn't go that far
just stayed right there see how far my
you